de 500 à 600 euros par hectare des
pertes catastrophiques selon les
agriculteurs franciliens
la récolte 2016 et inédite mercredi 31
août la présidente de la région ile de
france a présenté un dispositif de
soutien de plus de 6 millions d'euros
il faut être à leurs côtés il faut les
aider il faut être là et la mesure qui
nous ont proposé est une mesure
intelligente parce que l'idée c'est
d'éviter l'effet domino aujourd'hui ils
ont créé mauvaise récolte 6 m
les mauvaises graines qu'ils ont récolté
cette année ils ont une mode école
encore pire donc on va travailler sur la
qualité des semences on va aider à
acheter des bonnes semences pour que la
récolte soit meilleur l'année prochaine
les grains de blé porte les stigmates
des mauvaises conditions climatiques de
ces derniers mois moins coloré plus
petit
la récolte de lucien va les céréaliers
yvelinois a été fortement touchée lors
de la moisson en récoltant le grain
on s'est aperçu que les épis été formé
mais qui avait rien dedans c'est à dire
en épluchant
un épi de blé on s'est retrouvé avec 4 5
grains normaux et tout le reste des
petits grains ou ratatiner
malade une année normale en blé jeu
je suis en une moyenne de 80 85 quintaux
et
là je me retrouve
sur un rendement de 40 40 quintaux les
plus anciens d'entre nous nos parents
nos grands parents n'ont jamais connu
cette situation il était resté gravé
l'année 76 dans les mémoires qui était
une année de sécheresse celle ci qui
avait un pacte et durement les
rendements mais une année 2016 comme ça
qui impacte avec des niveaux de
rendement / 2d chiffre d'affaires divisé
par deux c'est quelque chose qu'on n'a
jamais connu le dispositif actuel
s'ajoutent aux millions d'euros déjà
débloqués par la région en soutien aux
agriculteurs touchés par les inondations